hello hello hello
and wait just a few minutes while
everybody is entering into the room so
nice to see so many names and and
oh nobody has their camera on yet come
and join me I want to see smiles
so my thank you Dr Wallach awesome
awesome awesome thank you Ruth Ellen
thank you Dr Judy thank you nasima and
jonty these are my co-hosts who are here
with me this morning if you're in the
Pacific time zone
um and anytime before
Eastern Time Zone
welcome I love the fact that we can join
uh come together any time of the day or
night and also catch the replay so if
you are here with us and you hear
something that you would like to share
with somebody else make sure that you
understand you are free to share this
information with others share this
replay you can find the replay on askdoc
live.com
um as the show is recorded on Friday we
have it here
are up on the website by Monday in most
cases and sometimes the same day so make
sure that you
um stay tuned and
um Cliff can I rename you
so
um we have it's gonna be a great great
show everybody it's gonna be a little
bit different today so
I hope that you are ready for askdoc
live as I had mentioned my name maybe I
didn't mention my name is Rebecca Dukes
Kozak and I am honored and excited to be
the host of ask doc live we have been
doing this for over two years each and
every week and I think we've only missed
one
so just having that consistency and
being somewhere that you can count on
coming to get information that is going
to be beneficial for you and your loved
ones and your community in creating the
health Journey that you would prefer
so the information that is shared today
is not something that you're going to
hear from most people in a white coat in
a big building or even a small building
if you go to a small clinic but we are
excited to be able to share information
that has worked for us
um and as you're gonna hear today
some of us have been working on this for
a very long time before finding the
solutions that we share with you today
and once finding the solutions that we
shared can't believe how simple it
actually was so
I without I want to I have to make sure
that I don't forget
um that if you are here live with us
today uh we do have a chat function so
make sure that you have that chat open
so that you can see the valuable
information that our co-hosts are
sharing in that chat
if you have a question that you would
like to ask you can put it in the chat
but I prefer that you find that virtual
hand I like to go through the hands
those that are
um here with us
in the chat sometimes it goes so fast I
might miss you and I don't do it on
purpose please forgive me if I've missed
you in the past but raise your hand and
I will be sure to see it and we call on
those people in the order that their
hands are raised okay so the content of
this program is to provide educational
information only on the importance of
nutrition and supplementation because
folks let's face it even in the 1930s it
was published by the U.S government that
the soil does not have the minerals in
it and plants do not make their own
minerals so if the minerals are not in
the plants
the plants don't have them in the food
that we eat that comes from plant
sources
and minerals are the currency of life we
cannot Thrive without the appropriate
nutrients so it does take us being
intentional to not just survive but
Thrive and in this program we will be
sharing options that we have found like
I said proven to give us what we need
fills those gaps and for me
they're not essential
they're My Life Source
I would not go a day without them
because I've tried and I feel the
difference and I love the way that I
feel now
when I am giving my body what it needs
not just to survive but Thrive and the
information that we have to share with
you today is coming from Decades of
research from an individual who did the
research himself yes he looks at other
people's research and he takes that
information into account and sees
whether or not yes he agrees with it or
disagrees with it
but he also gives us
a foundation not just say because I said
so he actually has that foundation and
proof that things are the way they are
and with that proof he has been able to
claim over nine victories
against the FDA which requires me to let
you know that
the contents of this program is not to
take the place of your primary care
physician that it is here
to provide informational purposes or or
for informational purposes only and the
products discussed are not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease if you are pregnant nursing or
taking medication please consult your
primary care professional before
starting on any program when it comes to
food and what you put in your mouth but
let's use a little bit of Common Sense
and
get some education on
what is needed to have a thriving life
and to do that
we are honored to have with us a
co-father of the science of epigenetics
so for some of you epigenetics might be
a new word
let me give you a little information to
help arm you with some knowledge
so epigenetics is science so whenever
somebody says well I want to see the
science behind it well let's go to
epigenetics because epigenetics is a
study on how your behaviors and
environment can cause the changes that
affect the way your genes work and are
expressed
okay in epigenetics you're an empowered
individual that has not been taken away
from you you are not dependent on
chemicals or somebody to say oh take
this to cover I'm going to stop there
sorry jaunty anyways the testimonials
shared on this program are voluntary and
the individual's personal experience as
a result of the products that we will be
mentioning today
that have been recommended by our good
doctor Dr Joel Wallach now Dr Wallach he
has been actually nominated for two
Nobel Prize sis and he's also the
recipient of the 2011 claw Schwartz
commemorative medal lifetime achievement
on natural medicine and florantrophy
from the United Nations and in 2015
there's the United Nations
2015 was the United Nations thank you Dr
Wallach I'm so glad your memory is
better than mine
but anyways folks
welcome to askdoc live and welcome Dr
Wallach how are you today
fine thank you and just a great great
beginning we have so many good things
happening so I'm not going to take a lot
of time I'll start out here you just
interrupt when it's time for me to shut
up okay
I'll do it nicely okay the the issue you
were talking about U.S Senate document
264 1936 the United States Senate uh
posted U.S document 264 and said you're
no longer a sufficient
um nutritional minerals in our food to
support human health
okay that was the U.S Senate 1936 you're
going to send document 264 that's very
scary because they know little or
nothing about nutrition but so when they
came out with something it's it's very
obvious that it's obvious that even they
recognize we have a problem
and um uh what got me interested in this
was when I was a kid when I was five
years old I began with something they
didn't even have a name for in the
beginning it's called Tourette's
Syndrome I had a very violent Pharma
Tourette Syndrome very disruptive by the
time I was nine years old they were
going to put me into a institution
because 20 doctors over the over the
five or six years whatever it was
couldn't figure out what was going on
they couldn't figure out what I had but
they knew I was getting more violent I
was going to wind up killing somebody so
they're going to put me into a
Institution for the rest of my life that
didn't sound very good to a
nine-year-old so on Friday night they're
going to send me the institution on
Monday my Mom and Dad are packing my
clothes and everything and I'm sitting
on the end of the bed and I'm saying
well why is it our farm animals don't
have what I've got we're eating the same
food living in the same place why do I
have this problem
and then I thought well we're doing
something different from that for them
and so
um the next morning
I went to the barn and I got the Alfalfa
pellets we were feeding the calves
there's had vitamins and minerals added
to them they weren't just Alfalfa but
their Alfalfa pellets the vitamins
minerals actually I started taking them
for Saturday morning Sunday morning
Monday morning and by three o'clock in
the afternoon Monday morning I was cured
after five years and 20 doctors couldn't
figure it out so I knew when I was nine
years old that the medical system really
had a shortfall they didn't know what
they were doing obviously if you're shot
or fall off a tractor and broke your
neck you need to go to the doctor but
when it came to Health and Longevity
they really didn't know what they were
doing I I figured that out when I was
nine and so that's when I really got
into
the task of chasing down
the stories you pointed out very clearly
uh the 25 million dollar grants we got
for a 10-year period
um Marlon Perkins the old Mutual Kingdom
show got those grants based on my first
scientific paper which I uh did uh I had
to work my way through school I got my
degree in agriculture I was working
towards a Veterinary degree but I
couldn't afford everything so I was
working part-time Pathology Department
and
um it was the Christmas holidays
1963 all the professors were gone I'm
there by myself and this farmer brings
in 50 dead lambs and dumps them on me he
said well the day before
um
all 500 of those Lambs were perfect six
months old in a week or so they were
going to go to uh you know that would be
slaughtered made into lamb chops and so
forth and then the next morning that
morning they brought me those 50 dead
Lambs they were all dead
well in in December in Central Missouri
it could be 35 40 50 degrees and that's
what was going on but the night that
they all died the night before they
brought me those City Lambs the
temperature dropped to 16 and they all
died of hypothermia I got it figured out
and wrote it up and
um got it published in 1965 when I was
on my way to Africa for Marlin Perkins
to work on the Rhino project there's
only 350 left and the uncle ocean game
reserves in Natal South Africa White
Rhino today there's 21 000 because of
our efforts in creating all kinds of
parks and so forth so every kid who's
interested in conservation needs to get
a hold of this book Rhino Express and
um they need to get a hold of the book
epigenetics which is a summary of my
10-year study 20 000 autopsies we're
talking about
let's see here 17 000 some change over
454 species of animals from all the zoos
and um 1 700 almost 2 000 humans and the
whole purpose of that study was to find
a species of animals uh that died of the
same disease as the humans did that we
could use them like the canary in the
mind like the old coal miner is used to
carrying the mind so the animals are
down in the zoo from pollution we knew
to evacuate the cities it was the whole
purpose they've sold my thesis uh which
is 5 000 pages
sorry
about that
um it's okay Doctor well like we can't
hear that so just keep going oh okay but
I I heard it so just disrupting me so I
had to turn it off okay turn it off okay
and so anyway
um the the summary is in the Smithsonian
Institute actually I should take that
back the the full
um 5 000 pages in the Smithsonian
Institute of the National Treasure and
the summary of it
um let's see here is
um 300 pages okay and so we're very very
proud of this and so epigenetics
everybody should have this book because
it goes into all the not only pollutants
but also all the nutritional
efficiencies it causes that have
problems again my thesis is in the
Smithsonian Institute of the natural
treasure that
um summary epigenetics started a whole
new science the death of the genetic
disease okay the death
Dr Wallach I'd like to interrupt you
right there for a moment yes for two
reasons
one we hear about thyroid issues
abundantly now yes
abundantly and think about it folks
Lambs are warm-blooded animals we are
warm-blooded animals what did he find
that was the cause of their death okay
and they they all died from
hypothyroidism okay what yeah they all
had a thyroid issue and that's because
the neighboring Farms wanted to get more
um
results from their from their fields so
they added more and more nitrate
fertilizer and the fertilizer was
running off the surface into the ponds
that these Lambs are getting their
drinking water from and so nitrates are
things that disturb thyroid function
okay so all these Lambs had goiter they
had hypothyroidism so that was a title
of my paper because I really didn't you
know I'm only a kid and I don't know
that I realized the entire importance of
that study in the beginning and so
instead of talking about the pollution I
just said the title was hypothyroidism
in theater labs okay I got it published
in two Veterinary journals yeah so you
you discovered something and published
it
and now looking at our diets folks
do you read labels
do you know how many things have
nitrates in them
almost all of your processed foods yeah
your lunch meats
even cheeses
um what else Dr block oh grains
drains grains yeah
I'm even finding that they use it in
jerky which originally I thought that
was safe it's just dried out meat right
well no it's not they're using nitrates
as preservatives
so if you have any of the conditions
that Dr Wallach mentioned
take a look at what you're putting in
your mouth because chances are you are
on a high nitrate diet that is affecting
your thyroids function
and then also the foods that you're
putting in your mouth in addition to
that that are preventing the absorption
of the good stuff that the body needs
and the Brain well yeah I mean we want
to have good brain function right all
the way through to the day that we say
adios
at over a hundred and twenty
that's my
that's my thought that's my goal so next
thing that I wanted to interrupt you for
Dr Wallach is epigenetics
that is the summary of your thesis
that's correct this is the summary this
is a summary my 5 000 page
um okay and um as I said it was there's
300 pages and it's uh
uh 373 pages okay three well 373 Pages
Dr Wallach yes this I have gotten
feedback from many people saying how is
it that Dr Wallach is not charging more
for this book
and I'm here to let you know the price
is going up because I've heard it from
more than a handful of people
um so if you are interested in getting
epigenetics make sure that you go to
askdocklive.com we have a link there or
drjwalik.com and get your copy of
epigenetics it's an amazing book I
absolutely love it I have it right here
I use it as a reference all the time
when I'm looking at different conditions
um and just having that knowledge helps
me understand
why my supplements are so important
because without them
without adding them to my diet Dr
Wallach
I would be sick and miserable yes well
it shows very clearly there are no Jacob
Transmissions there's no autoimmune
diseases which was the fallback position
for all medical doctors and pharmacists
they didn't have you know a diagnosis
like broken arm broken neck that kind of
stuff a heart attack they would say oh
you have a geography you know three of
your parents for the last 500 years
three of your relatives for the last 500
years had all these same diseases well
they lived in the same county or you
know live in the same state nutritional
minerals are not occurred in a uniform
blank around the trust of the earth
occur in veins like um like um gold and
silver and if I make it kind of show
this by the the life expectancy of
different countries if I may real
quickly just you know less than two
minutes kind of thing okay
um and basically uh the the ER doctors
emergency room doctors United States
their life expectancy according to the
medical association in America is 58. 58
okay and the Philippines their life
expectancy 71. I just did a big thing
with them last night our Zoom with him
regular zoom in the Philippines 71. and
the USA are depending on Whose data you
look at are life expectancy 75-79
Australia is 82.9 New Zealand is 82.3
Japan is 84.7 Canada is 84 are you
beginning to get a picture here okay uh
China's 76. the UK is 81. Russia is 72
South Africa is 63. Mexico is 77 Italy's
83. uh Ukraine is 71. Spain is 82.
Germany is 81.26 I thought that was
funny Egypt is 71 and the hunzas are
120. now why is that well they live in
the Himalayan Mountains and they don't
have big cities like New York and St
Louis and la and Chicago
they live in little Villages and valleys
in the Himalayan Mountains and their
little village might only have 50 people
in it I only have three families okay
and so
um they have access to all these
volcanic minerals
okay not only from the volcanoes but
also the glaciers driving and so all
their crops are grown in this High
mineral soil okay with over
um 70 different minerals and that's
where we get our plant minerals from
that's why we went there to get to plant
minerals was from these areas the
Himalayan salt and the the Himalayan
plant minerals uh even our rebounder
sports drink has 75 minerals in it and
25 items and and so forth
um Red Bull only has one mineral
magnesium
Red Bull only has one mineral magnesium
Red Bull only has one mineral in it
magnesium ours has 75 and of course one
of the co-founders of Red Bull I'm just
very sad for his family and everything
I'm not you know not disparaging him but
he drank 10 cams a day of that Red Bull
with only one mineral in it and he died
at 78.
okay is primarily at B vitamins
um sugar and caffeine and that was Red
Bull ours our rebound has 75 minerals
and 25 items amino acids in it so which
one is going to be more nutritious I
mean you don't have to be you know a
university scholar to figure that one
out
so I urge everybody to use our rebounds
forward shrink if you're going to drink
the cans pop the tops
um they do have carbonation in the cans
they don't have carbonation in the
um on the canisters okay they don't have
carbonation in the canisters uh or in
the sticks but they do have carbonation
in the cans okay so what I do is I pop
the tops I'm not going to do it here
mess up my disk if I pop the tops from
two of them every night before I go to
bed and then you put them in the
refrigerator so in the morning they're
flat all the bubbly is gone it's off gas
and so I can safely drink it so I'll
drink about a third to a half with
breakfast a third to a half again with
lunch or dinner and so that's how I
drink my rebound if I'm you know going
to be doing some heavy stuff during the
summer time doing a lot of sweating I'll
drink too uh those cans during the day
but I popped the tops the night before
and they're flat all the bubbly's gone
okay well and as Janet I mentioned
rebound is delicious I personally prefer
the canister
just just saying it has less sugar in it
it's and it still tastes great you're
getting all those minerals and it
actually has more of the vitamins and
minerals in it than the can I'm just
gonna throw that out there folks plus
hey turn it around so we yes we see Theo
Theo's on that that panel of the
canister but as you turn it around keep
going keep going keep going it is
rebound FX and that's actually a perfect
segue Dr Wallach into our guest and here
jonty's got his I was just looking for
my canister but I don't have my canister
but I have 32 ounces of it right here
um so some people say how do you stay so
energized well one I take my Beyond
tangy tangerine and my Osteo effects and
my efas and my selenium
and then for hydration
I have my rebound I have my smart I have
my soul I mean all of these Alternatives
that are healthy that I'm continually
feeding my body
with nutrition
and I'll tell you what it's paying off
it's paying off I don't have
I haven't had to do any type of
strenuous exercise I mean very little
exercise stretching yes I love to go for
walks yes
but that's all I've done Dr Wallach
Nutrition a little bit of exercise and I
have a hundred pounds gone
because of what I have been watching on
giving my body what it needs so it
doesn't feel like it's in Starvation
mode anymore well I have to salute you
for you know doing a great job and of
course I do walk three miles a day I
walk two miles in the morning one mile
in the afternoon
um
I walk one mile and then I have lots of
stuff to do and then I an hour and a
half two hours later I walk another Mile
and uh after my two hours of radio you
know have all kinds of things to deal
with for an hour and then I do my third
mile every day I didn't been doing it
for I don't know how many years
um and so forth and I played I played
football and wrestled and uh that sort
of stuff all through Junior High and
high school and University lettered in
all the sports
um and so on I only weighed 110 pounds I
was taking on guys for like twice
literally twice my size or 200 pounds
and they hated to see me coming
uh Dr Wallach I have a couple questions
for you
I know that you have recorded a lot of
lectures yes
and there's a lot of Publications that
you have written have you ever written
and recorded a song
have you ever written recorded a song I
have to think about that
um have you ever acted in a movie
however I have to think about that I
know I've been on a lot of film on DVDs
and CDs and TV programs but I don't know
that I was in a movie
well let's take and visit with somebody
that's a few Generations behind you Dr
walk who has done those things and I'm
excited to welcome my friend Jesse
medallis and for those of you who may
not have heard about Jesse if you have
kids and grandkids
they might have heard of him because
Jesse Welcome to our stock live
hi George
um so Jesse is he he's a Latin
songwriter and performer he's a recorded
artist he has videos
um he's been in how many movies I think
I counted 12 or 15 different movies that
you've been in and he has an amazing
story on where he actually has a degree
from the medical industry
and he depended on them for his house
for many many years
and he's going to share just a slight
Glimpse because we're going to be doing
a full testimonial with Jesse but we
want to make sure that you
who are here with us and watching this
replay just get a taste of how impactful
giving your body what it needs
makes not just to make it to the next
day but actually Thrive and enjoy
and look forward to getting old so Jesse
Welcome to our stock live my friend hi
thank you for having me and um well I'm
excited to be here because and share the
results
in a week and a half the crazy results I
still feel like okay this is not normal
what's going on but um a quick story
about me so I um
about a year and a half ago
um
I well I've always suffered from a
herniated disc um I cured it through
um um acupuncture things like that they
wanted to do surgery all this crazy you
know how health care is the first thing
they want to do is cut you up break you
apart and and
um well that's what they wanted to do to
me so basically
um that was good all of a sudden one day
I was getting up and I felt this extreme
sharp pain on my lumbar like if I was
getting electrocuted I couldn't
understand what that was so I ignored it
about
six seven months later
um I had an extreme horrible sensation
burning sensation on my abdomen and it
was so painful that my stomach like like
inflated it was burning I don't know
what was going on I followed I do have a
degree in healthcare
um um in healthcare I do have a uh
personal training certificate that I do
have the whole thing of nutrition I do
so for so many years I I was experienced
at that
um the scary thing about it is when that
happened the first thing I did is
emergency room things like that they're
like no you're healthy the next day I
woke up sweating and and even like more
it won't even try to like put water in
my mouth and my stomach would burn I
don't know what was going on so I went
back to emergency room I did that I'm
gonna cut out everything
um I'm shorter but the suffering was
horrible I did that for about four
months emergency room six seven times a
week I was getting worse I was starting
to feel dizzy lightheaded like every
symptom of a human being could have I
started doing that
I started feeling like um that I
couldn't figure out what was going on I
tried everything from protons from
everything I did that I saw uh uh a
gastrologist now you're playing this and
that blob lights in your head no you're
this whatever all this crazy stuff um
drink of volume drink um Xanax drink
this and then
um my stomach started bleeding now I
bled out
um it was kind of scary uh my organs
started like shaking and I started
getting worse then I called the
gastrologist and I'm and and I'm like I
need an endoscopy I need a colonoscopy
because of my knowledge in healthcare I
went and did all that and they said oh
you just said let me just try this it's
okay nothing that but so much was going
on in my body like um it was not normal
I was in pain
um I had to for like four months I had
to lay on the floor and because if I
would stand up I felt like I was gonna
pop the pain was horrifying I just I
didn't want to live like that I'm like
no no I don't want to live anywhere that
was what was going on into my mind this
is like Fast Forward into like four six
months in that excruciating pain finally
they did the endoscopy colonoscopy oh
you're healthy things like that the
doctor gave me some pills
and um I'm sorry for my language these
idiots
um well this idiot did it he crossed did
medications which made me worse and I
got to the point where I felt I was
gonna die I was rushed to the emergency
room my whole body was my organs I think
were going in shock and then um I bled
out more and then um I call him I'm like
um you know keep drinking and keep
drinking I'm like no this is not normal
you can't mix these I did my own
preachers he's like oh okay we'll just
discontinue that one and in my mind I'm
like I'm supposed to be trusting you
would it like like you could have killed
me and so then I continue
um going with this doctor I um
eventually like a month after I
discontinued him I go with the second
opinion it was a a bigger idiot sorry
for my language and um oh no you know
what it's okay
um take um um you could be on Pro
something comes for the rest of your
life if you need them don't worry I just
send you send you more if you're feeling
like that I'll give you use Xanax I'm
like so you basically wanted me to be a
zombie in bed and just basically be dead
this doctor then says um when I told him
I started at that point getting so
scared I started researching
um what can I do to start curing myself
what can I do like this is not working
and remember I have so much years of
experience through healthcare because
that's where my degree is everything but
I started feeling like this is not right
he's trying to treat a symptom not the
root cause what's going on like
everything started just being unmasked
for what I had learned
I go with this doctor one last time and
then I remember telling them like this
is not normal I'm like so I had to go
and lay on the back of the the um the
van that
um take me because if I stood up I felt
like I was gonna pass out on my stomach
and I told him doctor but do you realize
what this does in long periods of times
have you done the proper research oh
well don't worry that's why they have
dialysis if your kidneys fail and in my
mind that was my aha moment that's when
I'm like this I am not gonna I'm done
with with this with this whole situation
with this doctor remember I've been I
was like almost a year just thrown on
the floor it was like um
um on my back
um the stabbing if I tried to walk I
couldn't my stomach now like they it
started out from my stomach and then
they turned it into a lot of crazy
issues through the side effects of those
horrible chemicals that they put into my
body
um I had over six CT scans four MRIs
everything blood work
um and sedatives I went with
um neurologists Orthopedics over nine to
ten doctors and none of them could
figure out what was going on
finally I stopped listening to that
doctor and I'm like I need I'm gonna die
I had dropped down to 90 pounds from 155
to 90 pounds and they were still and
dropping down pounds by the Dell some
malnourished I have a picture that I
could always send to Rebecca where
um my my own bones I felt like a
skeleton
and I felt horrible I just I didn't want
to live like that I started looking at
Switzerland other countries like the the
amount I couldn't stand because my the
the static Pains of nerves I don't know
what was going on my stomach now and so
I started looking at other countries
saying like Okay I just want them to
give me a shot and just take me out of
this misery and I'm sure a lot of people
could relate and um um twitching muscle
twitching muscles like everything just
24 7. so if it wasn't my brain going
crazy because of the twitching or
whatever they call it neuropathy or oh
it's benign something don't worry it'll
go away or my stomach or my back I had
gone to one doctor for one issue and all
of a sudden I had over 15 different
issues going on with me
and then I finally started you know what
I gotta start checking how good my my
hand my own thing I had to unlearn
everything I've learned from healthy I
want to get into the holistic world I
started researching a lot started
juicing fasting I started just doing my
own thing immediately I started getting
better from my stomach I started doing a
lot better still not 100 I was new to
this and I started doing better within
three four months I cured my digestion
through
um food and through certain herbs
minerals I was ordering like
um certain
things that they want to give me like
Xanax I would look at the holistic or
what can I replace that with
eventually the the the thing that got me
really angry is when I went back with
that doctor just for a follow-up just
courtesy you know how insurances work
um I went back there and and I said I'm
good and that and he's like are you
still taking my pills I told you you're
better I'm like no I'm not I
discontinued all six pills that you had
me taking because even the two of them
that you shouldn't have mixed all the
pro pumps because Pro pumps messes up
your whole stomach just your whole
anatomy of your body all this stuff I
was so like semi knowledge at that point
and I told him yeah I'm good now I could
eat now I I feel better than when I felt
like when I was 17 you're like that's
good I told you I was thinking about
like no I I did just stop listening to
you and that's what helped me and I'm
like and now I don't have I seriously I
don't have this and that and he told me
he told me
um um oh and I at that time have gotten
into a holistic um program and um um
with the doctor and he also helped me
through certain things
um and um
and now I'm back with that doctor and he
told me oh can you give me his number
because I don't want to take this poison
either I deal with a lot of stomach
issues and in my mind I'm like I was so
mad I'm like this idiot was basically
giving me something that he does not
even trust
even through that process when I went
with my other the doctor that gave me
the volume or want to give me Xanax all
this crazy stuff he said I would not
even take that it's good you're on
ashwagandha because well why would he
prescribe it to me
all that started happening at the very
end and that's when I said
I don't want to do this I don't want to
do this
I was able to I'm healing a lot of stuff
by myself but still the twitching or I
don't know what you want to call it
neuropathy or the weirdness in my body I
felt like it was it does not feel good
like I and I did every test see these
kinds of the brain of the back um MRIs
um neurologists did the um where they
put the needle and checked that there's
signals going to the right areas
everything would come out good so I
started feeling like hopeless and
feeling like there's a p big piece of
the puzzle missing to my healing there's
a huge piece missing and I couldn't
figure out what it was on my own until I
came across um Dr Wallach video a friend
of mine we came across through the whole
holistic stuff and things like that and
um well actually this is the friend that
pretty much began the process Native
American and started telling me
um oh no we're not in my days my culture
we don't care to the poison because
um um they treat a symptom not the root
cause they're like we do herb and that
was the first person like okay whatever
that's the first person that got me out
of the the believing in
my personal opinion into the Health Care
system
but um then I met um I came across Dr
wallach's video and I it made so much
sense it made so much sense I had
already um researched Dr sebi so many
other doctors
um and I started becoming a bit obsessed
over Dr Wallach researching a lot of his
stuff watching his videos everything he
talked about even listened to a
testimonial he did um um my thinking I
don't know it was a Mexico or something
it was like part Spanish and then he
started speaking in English where it was
translated
um because I'm Bilbo and I contacted
them and I was still like a not remember
I had tried a lot of also other holistic
stuff and it just was a waste of money a
waste of my time and things like that
not discrediting them but when I came
across Dr Wallach I came in with one
foot in one foot out and I decided to
join one of their three-month program
um with no expectations at all and um
Within
and and I gotta give credit to Rebecca
one of the main reasons that got me to
actually even really entertain us are
amazing customer service her good heart
and her guidance and
just everything about her and then of
course the genius of Dr Wallach who
created this products but I tried them
with no expectations no believe in okay
you know what I'm just living life
within a week
something that I had for a whole year of
the Twitchy than this and that and
Rebecca's videos and they're like worms
like I would sit down here and I was
holding my body because it's like all
this crazy twitch neuropathy sometimes
burning and all this weirdness within a
week
um 70 to 80 completely gone
I'm sitting here right now with not one
muscle movement not one I have no
burning or or all of a sudden a shocking
here like a little not one I could see
as of now within a week week and a half
there's 70 to 80 percent
um gone sorry
once in a blue moon I'll get a little
bit of twitching but it's so minor or a
muscle most things like that but it's
starting to feel like
like my boss told me like hey it's
healing hey is this so now those are
starting to feel like like
I don't have the right signals are being
thrown I'm not a professional I need to
ask Dr Wall like that but
it's a year with 10 doctors
of the the piece of the plus I couldn't
um figure out and I could say today I'm
I'm a Believer and sometimes I'm like
okay why isn't it moving also it wasn't
and I'm like scared that it's all just
gonna start coming back but
I'm feeling so much better
my mental Clarity is
surreal
um I was eating a lot of healthy food
and even my food changed through this
whole process and um but I felt
malnourished I felt a bit fatigued I
felt like like even though I was
following a strict diet I still was not
getting
something my body just felt malnourished
and and um
now I put on four or five more pounds of
muscle within the last week and a half
of my my S my body feels starting to
feel full again but in a good way and my
strength is back and and um
no anxiety
no depression no
um fear like
there's so much more going on
but I was just targeting one the the
last piece of the puzzle but I've been
seeing a lot of other stuff going on
when I would do push-ups and all that
this arm right here
um sometimes I'll get pains so I'll
always be careful how I do it and I
noticed the last few days I've been like
so like what the hell is going on so I
go back to Dr wallach's products I start
reading and it also throws minerals to
the cartilages and gets everything back
healthy so now it's all making sense
okay so that's what's going on so now
I'm super addicted to the products the
way it makes me feel the quality of life
is
I'm gonna say where that my family
doesn't like I always say it's
Immaculate right now that part of the
quality of my life and I'm so excited to
get rid of the last 30 percent of the
whatever's going on what no doctor could
figure out
and so yeah that's a bit of my story I
try to break it all down close but it
was a whole year of doctor after doctor
after doctor after doctor
um 10 visits at one doctor 10 visits the
next Doctor 10 visits the neck doctor
machine after machine blood work after
blood work like that was the part that I
threw out just to not be here A whole
five hours talking to you guys about it
well Jesse I know that there's a lot of
people including myself
that went through all of these tests
and the medical
industry could not tell me what was
wrong with me
and here you found nutrition you started
giving your body what it needed
and got amazing results
and we are all here because of this
gentleman I don't know where he is on
your screen but he's just below me here
on my screen Dr Joel Wallach so Jesse
did you have anything you wanted to say
to Dr Wallach
um
thank you
you're very welcome and um if you're
listening at the beginning of the story
I went through the same frustrations you
did when I was only nine years old I
went to 20 doctors couldn't figure out
what the problems were and I cured it in
three days just by taking vitamins and
minerals and so I was only nine years
old when I figured it out and so it's
not like it's that difficult gravity is
not difficult to figure out okay he
tried jumping off your entire State
Building see how it works okay that's
one one of those things where you hit
the right key the lock opens very simply
and so when a kid nine years old figures
out something the 20
medical doctors couldn't figure out in
five years time uh and you went through
the same process you had many many
doctors couldn't figure out what your
problem was and
um they would look at you and they
couldn't see anything they thought they
could fix you know like a a broken back
uh that kind of stuff that's what they
look for and they didn't have any kidney
problems or they're going to put you
under dialysis I didn't hear you say
anything about blood sugar problems or
they can treat you for diabetes and so
on and so when you get out of the realm
of those few handful of diseases that
they deal with every day they really
don't know what they're looking for they
don't know what they're looking at and
they don't know how to deal with it and
so you have done a miracle Thing by
figuring it out yourself and we just
appreciate you and love you and we
welcome to you to the young Judy family
I appreciate it and yeah thank you for
discovering all this where would we be
at if you would not have discovered this
a whole year of just figuring trying and
trying and trying to help just get it
out so and I tried a lot of other
products from other holistic companies
but
I'm not saying they were bad but they
sound like kind of worked or maybe I
don't know about placebo effect but
um these actually you feel them you feel
them your youngevity yeah here's the
basic thing that we discovered
all
um animals all human beings require 90
essential nutrients for the basic needs
of every system in the body our bodies
are made up of systems the
musculoskeletal system the digestive
system the respiratory system the
neurological system the cardiovascular
system all the immune system all these
systems need the 90 Cent the nutrients
16 minerals 16 vitamins 12 ounces of
Three fatty acids and then we have we
call secret sauces
because these secret sauces are
specifically necessary for each system
for instance the easy ones are like
diabetes I can take somebody who's been
diabetic for 45 years and two weeks
they're not diabetic anymore because
it's not a genetic thing even if
everybody in their family's got it it's
just a very simple nutritional division
thing we came up with the sweeties and
so we just add the sweeties to the 90th
centurions to get the healthy blood
sugar pack okay the same thing with high
blood pressure you take the 90 essential
nutrients you throw in the ultimate
daily classic tablets and suddenly the
blood pressure goes away I don't care if
you've been on blood pressure medicine
for 25 years in two to six weeks it'll
be gone and you don't have to worry
about it anymore but you do have to stay
on the nutrients forever
as long as you need oxygen and water you
need these 90 cents of nutrients okay
and so you stay on the program and we're
just so proud and happy and respectful
to have you join our team with your
story because you have such a grand
story because essentially you kind of
figured out yourself because you knew
that whatever the doctors were telling
you wasn't working and you weren't
satisfied with it well I had to accept
this for the rest of my life my life is
going to be shortened because of this no
you kept looking that is a virtue okay
keep looking and looking and looking
until you find it so we're very proud of
you and we cannot thank you enough for
sharing your story and welcome to the
youngevity family thank you it's um the
last thing I want to say is I was trying
to Rebecca like you gotta talk tell the
world why haven't I would not have been
um told your story to I mean a video was
in the past about you and I'll send
Rebecca like well he needs to we need to
promote him on TV we need to like there
I don't understand it's simple we ran
into you ran into the right angel you're
into the correct Angel when you ran into
Rebecca yes and she deals with people
from all over the world literally from
all over the world I don't know how many
how many 50 60 different companies she
cutting out companies countries that she
deals with and uh so she's seen
everything and so you you came across
the right Angel you listened to her you
did what she suggested and you got the
results so we can't thank uh Rebecca
enough and we can't thank you enough
thank you so much
well I have to thank social media
because social media is how Cliff found
us who then shared it with you
and it's that's what this is all about
folks is getting the information out
where people are looking
that's all it was and I have to thank
Heather because she helped me get the
social media page going so we all work
together as a family we are a community
and we just think all of you for being
here with us today Jesse thank you for
sharing your story of course
I mean I know that it's going to be
impactful to so many others
because they're going through some of
the same stuff you're going through even
if it's just bits and pieces
those bits and pieces are because of
nutritional deficiencies you're not
chemical dependent
you don't need to keep taking these
things that are going to eventually like
you said oh don't worry about it there's
kidney dialysis for that
really
that's not the way we were created folks
that's not the intention
for our bodies so let's take care of
what we were given and if you're not
exactly where you're at that's okay as
long as you're still breathing air
taking in oxygen it's not too late to
make some u-turns and make some positive
benefits in your health journey and in
your story
so again thank you Jesse I look forward
to more and following your journey
because I know it's gonna be great
you're gonna be back on the red carpet
soon
and Sharon youngevity with the world so
folks get ready get ready and
definitely look him up he's in some of
the even a current TV series that's
going on
um he has starred with some big players
and I'm excited to see him as a big
player here in the near future so thank
you Jesse appreciate you Rebecca if I
could just ask Jesse a question real
quick
uh medium promotions in the background
I really would like to be able to share
with our audience uh ways that they can
find out more about you connect to uh
your Instagram page or something yeah so
if you go to
www.jessymedeles.com which is
www.j-e-s-s-e-m like Mary e d e l e
s.com that's my um website on Instagram
I'm um it's at Jesse medeles which is
j-e-s-s-e-m-e-d-e-l-e-s
um or on IMDb if you want to see some of
the films I've been on you put in my
name
um IMDb says them all you can put my
name on Netflix and the film that I've
been on will come out there or just kind
of like if you're searching a certain
person it's the same
um protocol and I just put in my name I
know it's say all the movies I've been
in
cool well we got about 50
000 news I'll get an email in a couple
days
thank you so much
cheers man thank you appreciate the
story of course
awesome so like Doc is a really good
person to know jaunty he's my next best
friend when it comes to people to know
so everybody
um you know we are five minutes to a
break Dr Wallach do you want to go ahead
and take a quick break and then we're
gonna go to South Sudan
okay when we come back we're going to
Sudan
yeah
yeah Paul you can
how it's said
tune in to ask doc live my name is
Rebecca Dukes Kozak and I would like to
remind each and every one of you whether
you're here live with us or watching the
replay get back with the person that
shared this program with you they took
the time because they cared so make sure
that you care enough to take the time
and say thank you now in the next half
of this program we are going to be going
through different types of conditions
that people are experiencing and what Dr
Wallach would recommend for them to take
within a nutritional approach remember
he has done now over 30 000 autopsies
on 452 different species in one of those
species
is that human
and it's not just one autopsy more than
1700 autopsies on humans and taking his
information from his research as a
pathologist and veterinarian and
comparing it to that of what he was
Finding in the human body as well and
finding there's a direct correlation
when minerals are missing
dis ease occurs
so we will be right back in just a few
minutes if you have a question make sure
that you raise your hand go to the zoom
menu find that option to raise hand and
we will get to those hands in order that
they are raised if you would like to
follow along and see what our co-hosts
are sharing in the chat make sure you
have that chat box open
they're going to be sharing where you
can go to find information about the
products but again get back with the
person that shared this program with you
to get those products
if you have never spoken to anybody
before you found this replay this video
this zoom on your own
feel free to go to askdoclive.com we do
have a contact us
use that to reach out to us and myself
or one of my certified holistic health
coaches will get back with you
and make sure that you get the products
that are specifically aimed at helping
you
feel those deficiencies that are causing
the symptoms that you are experiencing
we have a whole course that teaches
about Dr wallach's philosophy about the
four areas of Health how nutritional
deficiencies affect those areas of
health and the crazy thing is folks
everything's linked everything's
intertwined
you got something going on here
like arthritis in your finger
it's throughout the body that's just
where the weakest point is and where
you're feeling it
so let's nourish the body as a whole and
give the body what it needs to actually
Thrive we will be right back after this
short break
all right I think that's our shortest
break yet
doctor well like go ahead and unmute
yourself I'm gonna put you on Spotlight
here with me
and then we are gonna go to our next
um person there we go
um and
I just want to I know Clement has some
questions for you Dr Wallach
and Clement is joining us from is it
South Sudan or Sudan
can you unmute
Clement can you unmute
Oh no you're unmuted but I can't hear
you
hey
um Clement if you could go out and come
back in make sure that you connect with
Device audio
that would be great because we
definitely want to hear you
so Paul maybe you can help them out
there
foreign
well yeah I can you hear me Dr Wallach I
can hear you okay
I was thinking maybe it was me that you
couldn't hear so
okay well hopefully he'll be able to go
out come back in connect with Device
audio and folks if you have a question
for Dr Wallach
feel free to raise your hand
um I don't see the whole Gallery so if
you're doing this and reason your hand
I'm sorry if I miss you go to
the zoom screen
and under reactions you will find the
option to raise hand
well Dr Wallach well we are waiting for
Clement to come back and
I don't know we've got a pretty cool
house here Clement let's see if you are
able to unmute and if we can hear you
yet
I still cannot hear you if you have not
said anything
foreign
Dr Wallach
I had somebody
um write in in an email yesterday
with a friend who has adult onset of
scoliosis
she has gone from five foot ten to five
foot six
okay and for those of you who don't know
what scoliosis is it's a it's a
curvature of the spine
I actually this person writing in is not
me but I actually
um was diagnosed with scoliosis as a
child at eight years old
um but
one thing that I've experienced which
I'm so grateful for
is
I didn't have to continue with that
enhanced curvature of the spine that
additional kyphosis so Dr Wallach what
would you recommend for somebody who has
a condition like scoliosis no other
health conditions
um other than
experiencing loss of muscle
okay well scoliosis is is a symptom of
nutritional deficiencies it's a
nutritional efficiency
remember I said all systems require the
90th Century nutrients and then there's
secret sauces for each system the
musculoskeletal system including the
vertebrae in the back
requires the 90 essential nutrients plus
the secret sauces the secret sauces are
MSM
are collagen peptides are Beyond osteofx
vitamin D3
okay those are basic ones we have more
but those are the basic ones and you
have to appreciate
um the the muscular cells
musculoskeletal systems very complex
system
and it does require an enormous amount
of nutrition because of the energy
requirements and physical structure
requirements and so forth including the
bones and the connective tissues the
cartilage and ligaments and tendons uh
the nerves the blood vessels it's all
part of the muscular system
and so
um I I like when people have
scoliosis which is kind of a version of
um
uh sciatica and sciatica is is the low
back okay and you can have scoliosis
causing sciatica uh you can just have uh
or the discs go away and the verb will
get closer together and start smashing
the
um uh nerves that come out from between
the vertebrae right
and there's all kinds of symptoms one
you get pain and numbness and tingling
so which um Jesse had and then I also I
get all kinds of problems with digestion
okay and you can get problems with
sexual stuff and and so on another one I
always ask people about do you ever how
many times you wake up at Ninth year and
people say oh man I get up three times
five times eight times ten times and the
women go through that also so it's not a
prostate problem so what's happening we
have osteoporosis of the skull oh can we
have a book and a CD that goes along
with that obviously approaches to the
skull okay there's 37 different diseases
you can get from osteoporosisco
including scoliosis all right and you
can be born with algebrosis called this
is not an old person's disease babies
are born with it okay and
um
uh it is one of those things where it's
a nutritional efficiency when you get
osteoporosis it's called squeezing this
spinal cord the spinal cord then tells
the urine bladder to urinate and you
start urinating three four times uh
every hour or every two hours or
whatever it is and so women actually
suffer from this more than men do so it
can't be a prostate film because women
don't have prostate glands okay it's a
male issue all right and so um basically
um this fella here
need to get rid of all the bad stuff no
fried foods we're talking about air
frying deep frying pan frying uh no oils
of any kind no cooking oils absolutely
no salad dressings uh get rid of the
processed Meats we're talking about ham
and bacon bologna salami uh we're
talking about hot dogs pepperoni jerky
corned beef spam all that kind of
stuff's got to go because of the
chemicals then no gluten so you can
maximize absorption no gluten maximize
absorption the only people who are nuts
there are people who are not sensitive
to gluten the only people who are not
sensitive gluten are dead people
everybody else you got to get rid of
wheat barley Rye oats and buckwheat and
peanuts okay and then you'll be drop
dead gluten free and then you need to
get rid of sugar no sugar okay and get
rid of no carbonation no carbonation I
remember I told you we had carbonation
in our rebound and so what I do is I pop
the tops on them on two of them before I
go to bed at night put them in the
refrigerator and then in by morning time
they're flat because all the bubbly's
gone and I can safely drink them okay
remember the co-founder of Red Bull just
died of 78 and he was drinking 10 Red
Bulls today for I don't know 25 years or
whatever it was
and he's a billionaire I mean he owned
all these kind of Red Bull Racing teams
and all this kind of stuff he was one of
the richest men in the world
and he died in 78 because he was
drinking 10 Red Bulls every day okay now
they didn't poison him but they did
prevent him from absorbing the things
that he needed to stay alive
okay and so it's one of those things
where you have to kind of pay attention
to the details so then again
um this guy needs two healthy brand
heart pasture month is it this is an
adult now right yeah and this is a
female doctor wallet I'm sorry from my
own research
you know females have more bone issues
than men do yes yes that's correct
why is that
because of their diet
they want to stay slim and beautiful and
so they avoid certain things and men are
like hyenas they eat everything boy they
just eat the bones they eat the
cartilage off the ends of the bones and
women don't do that women want to eat
peas and carrots and vegetables and
stuff and men tend to eat everything
including the bones and the cartilage
and the ligaments and tendons and skin
and all that kind of stuff and women
don't do that and so that's why women
have less of those kind of issues than
men because there's more nutrition in
those you know there's more nutrition
um in bones than there is in muscle
well there might be more nutrition than
in the bone than there isn't muscle I
sure like my steak Dr Wallach and
whenever and whenever I found out that
you weren't going to take that away from
me
I was excited
[Laughter]
but usually I don't care if you've had
scoliosis for your whole life you can
regrow it I do want them to hang upside
down on a one of those inversion tables
or say two three times a day I also want
them to put
a 4x4 beam underneath the feet of their
of their bed so they're going to sleep
their feet four inches above their head
so gravity is going to help them while
they're sleeping straighten things out
so the Grammy's even working on them
while they're asleep
and
um then they need again MSM they need
the vitamin E3 they need the collagen
peptides they need to be on Osteo FX
and um let's see here
um
what else let's just start there but
don't forget the rebound
well I am still gonna go with the powder
because it does have less sugar
than the can and you mentioned gravity
you know raising the the foot of your
bed using that gravity
that's decompression yeah and gravity is
cheap
gravity is very cheap
and well and I like I like my inversion
table as well in fact
with that inversion table when I first
found you I had come across an interview
that you had done and you had mentioned
an inversion table and so I got one and
after over a year after my car accident
of using that and spending
a lot of hours it was it was an hour to
the doctor our home from the doctor plus
an hour at the appointment for their
decompression therapies and having no
relief in fact felt worse
afterwards when I started on your
program I started using the inversion
table
I had no more disc issues
and I had had five of them that were
damaged in a car accident
so to no longer have that numbness and
tingling to no longer have that pain
that radiated
throughout my body
that was amazing and just no migraines
that was a bonus and everything just
started getting better and better and
better gravity is cheap
gravity gravity is cheap but you know
what
I'm worth the investment for the
supplements that I took
that did more than what gravity could
ever do
well yeah it's a good combination of
gravity definitely
um which I say maximizes the benefit of
the supplements
yeah well it
okay that works we'll go with that
let's see if we can get Clement again Dr
Wallach okay let me go ahead and unmute
yourself
and let's see if we can hear you
yes disclaiming are you getting me
we hear you welcome Clement
thank you this is Clement from South
Sudan
Sudan and it is uh yeah South Sudan
then it is night here
I have a question for you
are you getting me
yes we hear you
I have a vision
who is suffering from
hemorrhoid he has a recurrent
hemorrhoids
and he really is suffering from that one
and he undergone two operations
but the hemorrhoid
to come from the same place so
um I was from your
from the I heard of you so I said that
today I wanted to join you so that you
you give me the
clear recommendation what supplement
that we can do to give to such a case
okay so you're asking for patient that
has hemorrhoids
yes severe hemorrhoids okay how old are
they
is around
yes yeah okay and how much does this
person weigh
you wait
yes
please leave me like an approximate I
can say
because even because of this bleeding
and because of this stress is losing
weight
okay how much did he weigh 50 kilograms
dark huh about 50 kilograms 50 kilograms
so maybe 110 pounds okay 110 pounds okay
so
um this person uh needs to again uh put
a 4x4 beam under the feet of his bed so
his feet and his rectum in an anal area
is above his head when he sleeps for
four five six hours a night okay so the
pressure and the drainage is going to go
towards the head instead of laying flat
it's all going to go that direction okay
then this person needs
need one healthy brain and heart pack
one Hildebrand and heart attack per
month a half a dose of breakfast half a
dose of dinner needs one bottle a month
to the MSM for the connective tissue for
the tendons and ligaments both in the
muscles but also in the
um
blood vessels okay and so I wanted to
have the MSM
at 100 pounds 110 pounds they can have
one bottle of MSM take three breakfasts
three dinner time or two breakfast two
at lunch two dinner whatever is easier
for them six a day then
want this person also to take the um
let's see here M take the collagen
peptides let's go without the morning
drinks throughout the evening drink
there will be two canisters per month
and then we need the ultimate daily
classic tablets ultimate daily classic
tablet that's going to support healthy
blood pressure and healthy blood flow
through blocked blood vessels okay and
then we also want vitamin D3 even in the
Sudan I'm sure there's lots of sun it
needs a vitamin D3 to get the minerals
going in all the right places
and it doesn't hurt to actually again do
an inversion
um a table or say uh two three times a
day to let gravity pull things down uh
towards the chest instead of when
they're standing up it's all going
towards the hemorrhoids making it worse
all right or talking about the
connective tissue we're talking about
the blood vessels and so forth this is
easily repaired now one piece that I
mentioned but I want to really emphasize
it this person has got to get rid of
gluten no wheat no barley no Rye no oats
no buckwheat no peanuts this is forever
because these things interfere with
absorption no matter how much
supplements you're taking if you're not
absorbing them they're useless it's a
waste of money and time and so to
maximize the benefit from any supplement
program including ours they need to be
gluten free forever the only people who
are not sensitive to gluten are dead
people
okay back to you Rebecca
did you have another question Clement
no just this is this I guess I want this
uh for the remedy so he cannot go any
any surgery again
it's only this recommendation of Latin
so no surgery Dr Wallach just no surgery
no surgery
no surgery the only people who need the
surgery are the doctors
let's talk about
Dr Wallach okay don't offend my friend
here because it is a doctor
because he wants options to help his
clients around the world
standard doctor
he's not the standard doctor
that's right
so Dr well like let's talk about
hemorrhoids okay so him rights are
caused by a breakdown of connective
tissue in the veins and the muscles and
the colon and rectum
okay so giving the body what it needs
with the ultimate well the 90 essential
nutrients
with the addition of the cofactors of
additional selenium the ultimate sliding
because it has those cofactors in it
that make it work even better
and the MSM which helps with connective
tissue and the collagen peptides which
helps with connective tissue
you're given the body what it's missing
so that it can
as it's continually making new cells
have the raw ingredients that it needs
to make those cells right it'll repair
itself on a minute by minute hour by
hour day by day basis okay the body is
constantly doing that and again that's
why we came up with the programs we have
for young giving every system in the
body remember we named many of these
systems not all of them we name many of
the major systems most people know about
and in the reproductive system I didn't
mention right all of these systems
require that 90 essential nutrients
don't cherry pick one nutrient okay they
need the 90 essential nutrients but then
every system needs what we call secret
sauces now for instance let's go to
diabetes now when you have diabetes it's
not a genetic thing it's not an
autoimmune thing it's a it's a simple
nutritional deficiency of two nutrients
so when they get the a healthy blood
sugar pack they're getting the 90
essential nutrients of the healthiest
shark pack and we had two bottles of the
sweeties to it and the sweeties
um I'll say three at breakfast three at
dinner time for a hundred pound person
and guess what now within weeks the
diabetes goes away I don't care if
they've had it for 40 years you just
don't want a cold turkey off your
medication if you're on medication you
slowly reduce the medication as your
blood sugar drops
and another one that goes along with
that is pre-diabetes for instance
um in America okay in America
one-third of our population are
pre-diabetics one-third of the American
population are pre-diabetics if
everybody in America were to take our
healthy blood sugar pack
100 million people
within weeks would not be a pre-diabetic
anymore
and it's that simple okay and so they're
just not getting enough of these
particular nutrients people say which
one is it which one is it well I used to
tell people
30 40 years ago which one it was they
would run to the pharmacy they'd get
that one nutrient then six months later
I said well how's old Frankie doing oh
he died
he took that nutrient you said but he
still died because he wasn't taking the
90.
and so I stopped telling people what
that nutrient was but if you get the
book epigenetics you get the book uh
Dead Doctors Don't Lie get the book
let's play doctor let's be herbal doctor
now you get the book
um
rare earth wind cures I like rarest
Ventures you can go ahead and go to
chapter 10 and 11 page 272 and it'll
tell you how to collect the hair or to
ship it so you can find out how your
nutritional minerals are doing and what
toxic minerals you may have and then you
can fix all the problems because you're
getting there you go because you're
getting the information now
um medical doctors know nothing about
this they they think incorrectly
the type 2 diabetes is a genetic disease
no it's a simple nutritional
deficiencies
so simple nutritional efficiencies uh
this book
um was a research I did for Cystic
Fibrosis uh it's one of the reasons why
I got the clown Schwartz award in 2011
for finding the cause prevention and
cure for Cystic Fibrosis which doctors
thought were a genetic disease I found
the first non-human case in a rhesus
monkey that was going into space for for
the for the space program I was a
pathologist at the Yorkies Primary
Center at the time and Emory University
in Atlanta Georgia and they fired me
when I presented them with a paper with
all the research and all the data and
everything to get published she had to
present them you know the paper so they
could review it before he got it
published and they fired me because it's
a genetic disease as humans you can't
say it's in monkeys but I had five
papers the big medical schools in the
United States had signed saying it was
um it was in fact City for process but I
didn't tell them that the slides were
monkeys I just said I think these slides
are from an individual with a cystic
fibrosis what do you think and they
wrote back in a couple weeks on their
letter and say yeah these are classic
examples of cystic fibrosis and I told
them from a rhesus monkey and we had the
opportunity here to have some animal
models we can do more research they were
so excited and then when I told them
that it wasn't genetic it was a simple
nutritional efficient they say they
fired me
that's why I went back to school and
became a physician because they knew
they didn't know much
and we're going to figure out how we can
get your books to South Sudan all right
let's do it
so that's one thing that I have a goal
to do Dr Wallach and that is to get
information around the world
Clement did you have another question
that you would like to ask Dr Wallach
all right thank you so much Clement we
appreciate you and you know it just
foreign
language of the Sudan
uh the national language
now we are South Sudan we are not Sudan
anymore
so we are talking the the national uh
language is Arabic and English
you'll have to learn how to say Hello
Goodbye okay
yes
one more time Clement say it again
oh Shalom that's easy
okay
okay bye-bye thank you so much Clement
and nasima thank you
thank you Naseem
most welcome
nasima chimed in there
um so oh
I know Ruth Ellen had a question Ruth
Ellen
would you mind coming on you had a
client with a question let's go ahead
and get that question answered here
thank you okay hi Doc and hello
everybody
um so I have a question
um This Woman's name is Kathy
she says and I don't have any
information other than what she emailed
I have had diarrhea for almost two years
I have Diverticulitis and had an abscess
in my colon that put me in the hospital
for eight days
and
sorry I lost 25 pounds and could not
keep anything down including fluids the
only thing that kept me alive was the
prevalite powder the doctor finally put
me on
the bottom line is no diagnosis
I have had so many blood tests
colonoscopies endoscopies CT scans stool
samples and more can't leave the house
without a diaper
any ideas thank you for your time Kathy
gluten alert gluten alert gluten alert
gluten alert gluten alert okay none of
the bad foods no wheat brought around
oats no buckwheat no peanuts and then no
fried food no processed tomato oils uh
no um sugar no carbonated drinks
and then she needs she weighs 100 pounds
you say
uh we don't have any information
per 100 pounds she needs one healthy
branded heart pack per month if she
weighed 110 120 pounds she needs one
Health branded heart pack I take a half
of those really twice a day if she
weighs 150 pounds or 200 pounds or so
she's two Health abandon hard packs and
four of those are running twice a day
and then she needs her ultimate enzymes
she could take her ultimate enzymes take
two of those with all the gallbladder in
a bottle she can take two of those save
uh 10 15 minutes for each meal uh she
may want to get two of those bottles of
the ultimate enzymes and then I want to
use a rebound or a sports drink if she
can drink the can of she needs to pop
the tops then I prefers you can drink
and put them in the refrigerator then
take them out of the refrigerator in the
morning and drink one for breakfast one
for lunch or you can do what Rebecca
does and use the canister which is
powder doesn't have any carbonation in
it okay it has 36 servings in here
there's a tube in there one scoop is a
serving and a bottle of water okay and
there's a hundred nutrients in there
it's a quick way to get 100 nutrients
that's on top of the 90th Century you're
going to take with the hildebrain and
heart packs and then the and and then
the ultimate enzymes and then don't
forget the MSM because a lot of
connective tissue in the the stomach and
small intestines and most of their
looking they did was in the colon it
really didn't do much looking and then
from what lab data you said they were
doing they didn't really look at the
small intestine the small intestine is
supposed to look like a shag rug all the
finger like Villi in there increase the
absorptive Surface by 98 percent
when you have eaten gluten for three
months or six months all those Villa I
go away instead of looking like a shag
rub now the line of your intestine looks
like a plastic tube you've lost 98 of
your small intestinal surface the only
human beings that are not sensitive to
gluten or dead people
okay I agree you do not want to be one
of those okay no everybody needs to give
up gluten and you'll add 25 to 50
healthy areas of your life if you throw
in the 90 essential nutrients remember
all systems require the 90th Century
nutrients and then there are the secret
sauces for each system
it makes sense yes it does okay thank
you very much well you're very welcome
thank you rosellen you're welcome and
thank you Rebecca
all right well folks if you have a
question that you would like to ask Dr
Wallach don't be shy raise your hand go
to the reactions in the zoom in you and
find the spot where you can raise hand
Dr Willock don't touch anything on that
screen
so we're working on a whole new system
and folks you can teach Old Dogs new
tricks
so he's got this big old monitor in
front of him now so he can see
everybody's smiling faces if you're on
with us make sure you have your camera
on but make sure
um I shouldn't have to say that make
sure you're fully clothed
um and you're you're sitting here with
us present not just wandering around
doing a bunch of stuff running around
um with your camera on if you got your
camera on and you know we want to hope
that you're you're paying attention so
if we don't have any colors I can talk I
can talk about things like diabetes and
Alzheimer's disease and stuff like that
as they want
well
and talk about oh CJ has her hand up
CJ
go ahead and unmute
thank you so much Rebecca good morning
doc good morning Miss Rebecca question
for you dog I often hear you say to use
the in order for for weight loss to
replace one meal with the keto Chic if
someone wants to
um gain weight and with muscle mass do
you use the same Shake with the meal
okay stop there for a moment because
yeah our keto shakes are on back are we
we don't have them right now
and so we we have shakes that are not
keto shakes but they can still take one
shake as a meal replacer doesn't have to
be the same meal every day but as a meal
replace or it's not to add to a meal and
they'll lose a half a pound of two
pounds a day
gain weight gain weight and muscle mass
not to lose weight sir okay if they want
to gain weight yes one shake which we
have like I don't know four or five
different flavors you know strawberry
and chocolate and vanilla and that kind
of stuff they can take one shake with
one meal with a meal if they want to
lose weight they take a shake without
the meal it's a meal replacement not to
add to a meal but if you want to gain
weight they add it to a meal okay yes
and also they need the 90 essential
nutrients because to rebuild and build
muscle and bones and all that kind of
stuff you need all these nutrients you
just can't take a shake and once you
will gain is fat you don't want to just
gain fat you want to gain muscle and
bones that kind of stuff and so you need
to do it correctly yes sir he's already
on your program doc okay good yes sir
just wanted to ask yes sir and one one
more dog
um how many efas can someone take take
per day can you take a little extra if
you think you need sir
okay well
um what you can do if you want to find
out if you need more uh the next time
you go to your doctor you go to a doctor
go to a lab and say I want a blood
clotting test see what the time how much
time it takes for your blood to clot
okay if they take the needle out of your
arm and the blood clotted already you
need more more efas
okay if they take the needle out of your
arm they've said that syringe down they
come back four hours later and and um
uh you know the blood is clouded like a
um a piece of chocolate candy and then
you know you need more efas okay
okay yeah you have to use a little bit
of lab work to figure it out
okay sir thank you so much doc thank you
thank you Mr Rebecca you're welcome
Cynthia
and I would like to add to that Dr
Wallach as far as products that
youngevity has that helps in building
muscle because we want to not just gain
weight we don't want to gain fat like
you said we want to gain muscle
so amino acids are essential for gaining
muscle
and my favorite shape Dr Wallach is the
fit shake when it comes to gaining
muscle
the fit shake it has additional amino
acids it has additional collagen
peptides because
not you know connective tissue collagen
peptides with the bone broth
I should say it's bone broth which is
collagen
um which is a form of collagen peptides
you know let's get all this technology
pretty smart grandma was pretty smart
when she made bone broth yes yes so the
fit Shake
um is my favorite we do have two flavors
it's chocolate and then we have one that
is banana cream
I like the banana cream then I add an
extra banana in there and a scoop of
rebound
so think about that orange banana
and a nutritious drink so
um that's just one one thing that I like
and you were talking about efas with CJ
and
I mean essential fatty acids
Nature's
blood cleaner
if you've got thick blood
you need more essential fatty acids
right
yeah and you need the fatty acids they
they prevent asthma they prevent blood
clots
um not not blood clots when you cut
yourself but pathological blood clots
are cause stroke within the veins yes
okay and I know Dr Wallach asthma was
one of the things that I suffered from
um as an adult
it was crazy
because I couldn't it was hard going for
a walk and that was before I had gained
all my weight when I got pregnant with
my youngest and it totally messed up my
whole hormonal system
so getting on something that was
targeted towards correcting a hormonal
balance getting the nutrition getting
the essential fatty acids none of those
things are things that I have to worry
about anymore
and and it's a nice feeling that I now
have where I can go hiking
and not have to stress about whether or
not I have my inhaler
it's just one of those things
huh thank you so much for sharing well
you know as as mothers and grandmothers
we want to make sure we have everything
that everybody needs right and sometimes
we forget about ourselves yeah but
you're too young you can't be a
grandmother
I have four beautiful grandbabies oh my
gosh my angels yes
yes how old is your oldest child
33. you look like you're 33.
no he'll be 33 in December wow
you look like you're 33.
well thank you Dr Wallach not
I'm not but I'll take that so
excellent thank you
um so Dr Wallach let's talk about
what are more things that essential
fatty acids are important for
well the respiratory system requires
essential fatty acids when kids have
asthma and let me tell you how many kids
have asthma it's very very scary
um kids have asthma uh oh
let's see here there we are
um
gives younger than 10 years of age
okay we spend each year on in America I
mean kids under the age of 10 years of
age with asthma 80 billion dollars a
year
80 billion dollars a year just treating
kids on the age of 10 for asthma it's a
simple
um essential fatty acid deficiency so if
they take the healthy brand heart pack
uh and the
um MSM I take the vitamin D3
and of course the efas are in the
healthy brain and heart attack they can
take some extra if they're little kids
like you know under a year of age and or
three months of age because their
mother's still breastfeeding them get
our kids tidy okay it has all that stuff
in there but I want to add the extra
um efas you know added one EFA and one
EFA Plus in the evening and one if they
had breakfast puncture them and squeeze
them into the baby's food or if the
mother is breastfeeding she's got to
stay away from all the gluten so she can
absorb the vitamins mineral that's
supposed to be in the milk
but you're not going to have much in the
way vitamins and minerals in the breast
milk if the mother's eating gluten no
matter how many supplements she takes
and so that's why I like the insurance
if you will of the kids tati because
there's city of roses there's mustard is
free and you know the Jerry Lewis story
we we figured out much history
um after 50 years of working with the
muscles Association and the Telethon he
raised 2.5 billion with a B dollars for
them uh we gave Jerry Lewis
10 names of kids who we had cured I'm
using that word very loudly cured of
most of his feet okay with the nutrition
program and um Jonathan e mortar
attorney we went to the um federal
courts we beat the FDA in federal court
I don't know eight or nine times and
forced them to put Force the FDA to
require
the slim to be put into the uh baby
formulas by enfamiliar Similac and the
like and they did because the federal
course forced them to do that
and
we were able to cure these kids with my
sister so we gave it to Jerry Lewis he
got so excited he took it
um September 4th 2011.
September 4th 2009 I know the exact date
he took it to the most history
Association they some early he walked in
the door he gave it to him they fired
him immediately right then they canceled
the Telethon
and Jerry Lewis died within a year
okay but a terrible thing they did to
him he had raised 2.5 billion dollars
for the research he'd worked with them
for 50 years didn't charge him anything
for his time
and they killed Jerry Lewis
how crazy can you get well now it's in
all the baby formulas okay and plus we
have the kids Toddy and because of the
baby formulas are sometimes are here
sometimes they're not and we don't know
if these nutrients are in the baby Farms
are coming from all these foreign
countries okay so we got to make sure
that they're getting these nutrients
that's why we came up with kids toddy
one meal a day at least and these kids
under the age of six months need to be
on kids toddy after six months they
could start taking you know some of the
adult stuff okay now you can actually
take our liquid minerals and put like on
a little baby and put a half ounce of
liquid minerals on their belly buttons
and rub it on their tummy they'll giggle
and laugh and everything but they're
absorbing all those minerals for their
skin it's almost like IV
yes well and one thing that I like to do
Dr Wallach is I like putting it in a Mr
bottle
oh
and and misting it so especially for
those of you that are in hot areas the
Mr bottle with plant derived minerals
when you're sweating what are you doing
you're not just sweating out water
you're sweating out a slurry of minerals
that your body actually needs so let's
just spray it let it absorb back in and
replenish those minerals that are being
sweated out it's almost like I need that
workout
nothing like a Mr bottle you know how to
cool yourself off of course wipe the
sweat off first and then Mist yourself
let it absorb and naturally dry
um I I love that doctor because then
when you're pouring you don't have to
worry about it pouring off the body
that mist stays on the body you get
better absorption and why do we get
better absorption with our colloidal
minerals Dr Wallach because they're so
small and they come from plants they're
not ground up rocks I'll tell you a
quick story in just two minutes if I may
um Pastor Mike Freeman from Baltimore
Maryland he's you know one of our great
Pastors in youngeity along with Linda
Tyler up in that Bunch up in there and
she called me about 10 years ago and
said the Pastor Mike had been in a coma
for six months and the doctors just gave
him just a couple of days to live
um so everybody come better come visit
him he may or may not be able to hear
them but he's not going to live longer
in a couple of days now everything's
collapsing and is there anything we can
do I said does he have a G-tube we can
give him the minerals early no okay well
just take and soak some cotton balls uh
and and then you like a cup you know a
coffee cup size thing full of the liquid
minerals put them on his chest his belly
his back between his shoulder blades and
his lower back three or four times a day
she called me back in three days she
said
he got up this morning he shaved he went
back to work at the church and he told
the story and we have a set it's a DVD
and a CD set called Praise the Lord in
past 90. praise the Lord and pass the
90. it tells Pastor Mike Freeman's story
and that tells other people's stories
who have similar results that you can
absorb these minerals through the skin
so praise the Lord and pass the 90. what
a great great testimony to the body's
ability to heal itself now you know the
good lord gave us all these Avenues gave
us all these Avenues and we have a book
coming out that you're deeply involved
with it's called the um Wallach
Revolution right is that the title the
wallet revolution revolution the wall of
Revolution and that book goes into a lot
of these sorts of things all these
Miracles okay and so forth and so keep
your eye out for that when there's
another one coming out called the third
Testament the Old Testament was written
three thousand five hundred years ago
the New Testament was written two
thousand years ago and God has done many
many many many many many many many and I
could go on and on and on many many many
many many uh Miracles since then so he
took a lot of these Miracles since the
New Testament was written and put them
into this book called the third
Testament and we highlight the Old
Testament we highlight the New Testament
and then we highlight all the stuff
that's happened since then oh my gosh
the third Testament so watch out for
those two books they're coming
um hopefully before the end of the year
uh we're talking about maybe you know
within the next two months but certainly
within two three months those two books
will be out oh my gosh it's going to
propel human health to the sky it's
going to be good stuff
well and one thing that I want to add
um Dr Wallach and for those of you who
are with me
um in the Christian faith you know the
Bible says not to add to or taken away
take away from
there is no adding to there is no taking
away from this is just sharing
information that has happened
since the Old Testament was written it's
like a continuation of
that's it continuation the mighty
creator has been doing
it's highlighting what the Creator does
absolutely well Dr Wallach let's go to
Sarita who has her hand up Sarita my
dear go ahead and unmute yourself you're
on live with
Dr Wallach on ask.com how can we help
you Dr thanks Becca how you doing
awesome Dr Wallace working with a young
lady she has two kids and she's alluding
to the fact that both of them have
issues with ADHD
and what would you suggest for them
they're like one is six and the other
one is like nine
okay well when they have ADHD I had
something very similar I had Tourette
Syndrome okay it didn't have the name
ADHD back then but I had Tourette
Syndrome I had a violent form of it and
so they need to get rid of all the bad
foods the entire family Grandma Mom Dad
older brothers and sisters anybody who
comes to the house
they need to be gluten-free you know
wheat in a barley or mine oats no
um buckwheat no peanuts all that's got
to go no fried foods no oils no
um processed Meats no hot dogs bologna
salami pastrami pepperoni jerky corned
beef spam
um bacon and ham all that's got to go
again no gluten no wheat no butter Rhino
oats no buckwheat no peanuts no sugar no
um let's see here no carbon or drinks
even the diet one's got to go because
carbonation neutralizes stomach acid so
you cannot absorb minerals efficiently
or digest food
then I want to take
um let's see
take the
um if they if they don't want to take
the the pills and tablets and capsules
you know you say the older one is nine
or six but tells the old one the old one
is nine okay well nine years old they
can take uh one healthy brain and heart
pack for months take a half of those or
anything at breakfast have those during
the dinner time they also need to take
the synaptive take two of those at
breakfast take those two at dinner time
that'll be one bottle a month of the
synaptive
maybe two I forget uh how many is in
there
um that'll have the rain work they need
to eat two eggs twice a day with soft
yolks I had my three this morning okay
so I'm scrambling butter not margarine
hard boiled it'll count
fried will cause cancer gotta stay away
from all the bad stuff okay then they
need
um after meals not before meals but
after meals they need the rebound
not Red Bull not soft drinks not colas
none of that kind of stuff they need the
rebound
remember champion of um athletes use our
rebound okay just if you use a can okay
they need to
um pop the top put in the refrigerator
at night in the morning they can drink
them uh if they're just you know a kid
nine years old they may be only able to
drink a half of one otherwise we'll be
running out of the classroom all day to
go urinate five times an hour okay and
so they need to make sure that they're
doing it appropriate times
but um this is very simple okay they
need the 90 essential nutrients they
need the cholesterol which makes up 25
of the brain weight and 25 of spinal
cord weight we don't have enough
cholesterol you can get Ms multiple
sclerosis you can get deombre syndrome
which is multiple sclerosis of the
spinal cord very common in kids okay
and so and then you get
um
ADHD you get um
um let's see here you get Tourette
syndrome
all that goes away and you can prevent
it so you prevent it if you get it you
can get rid of it very easy with the
diet with the and the supplements
all right great thank you sir God bless
you call Cherokee let me know how those
kids are doing will you yes I will thank
you so much okay dear God bless you and
thank you so much
thank you Sarita
one thing that I'd like
is when I'm dealing with ketos with ADD
ADHD having the inability to like settle
down and focus to do their school work
Soul we have a hydration stick called
soul
and it has herbs in it that just helps
the brain to calm down and focus it
works really good for adults too who
have all of these different projects
going on and they just can't seem to
make Headway on all of them
from experience I thought I had a bottle
here it's on my other desk yep it's on
your other desk
um and one thing that I like to do and I
have had Dr Wallach try it also and he
he actually liked it
um I make soul in with plain Greek full
fat yogurt
and then add my own berries so you're
eliminating the sugar
okay those of you who need to watch
their sugar which is
all of us
reduce sugar everywhere you can and you
can use the soul or the smart or the
core a o this morning I had core a o
which is extra antioxidants make it
mixed in with my plain yogurt and then
topped off with some blueberries wild
blueberries I just love it
so there's a lot of things that we can
do to just continually feed our body
things that are going to be beneficial
instead of harmful
let's go to Jill with her hand up Jill
go ahead and unmute yourself you're on
live with Dr Wallach drive safe
hi Jill
I thought good to see you today you're
looking good I love your new office for
your I love your office
yeah I did
um I uh I'm working with somebody
who is
228 pounds
63 years old uh five eight he has all
kinds of Bone and Joint issues
um but specifically what I'm looking for
advice for is he has pancreatitis or at
least that's what they tell him when he
has tests done he personally does not
feel he has the symptoms that go with it
but they've done
um I believe CAT scans and several
procedures that they keep coming back
okay
about that okay we only have a moment
here so you see this guy weighs 200 and
something pounds
228. 228 okay yeah need to get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no air
frying no deep frying no pan frying no
oils of any kind of cooking oils no
salad dressings absolutely no no
processed Meats of any kind uh
absolutely no gluten no wheat no butter
Rhino oats no buckwheat no peanuts no
sugar no carbon or drinks you know the
diet one's got to go and then
um I would have them take two healthy
abandoned heart packs a month photo
shedding twice a day uh we need to take
two bottles a month of the MSM so you
take three of breakfast three at lunch
at dinner time he needs um to take two
scoops a day of the collagen peptides
one of breakfast drink want a dinner
drink so he'll need two canisters a
month for that he'll need to be on Osteo
FX uh two canisters of that per month so
you can take one scoop in his drink in
the morning one was drinking afternoon I
do that and I only weigh 142 pounds and
then I'll see here I also want to have
the uh synaptive take three of those uh
twice a day two bottles a month you need
three eggs twice a day three eggs twice
today of soft yolks soft scrambling
butter or sauce soft scramble and butter
soft poached and butter okay uh no fried
no hard boiled
and
um let's see here what what were all the
symptoms again
I don't want to miss anything
pancreatitis
ultimate enzymes take
um two or three of those say 10 to 15
minutes for each meal with a couple
ounces of water okay we'll call it the
gallbladder bottle we could also say
it's the pancreas in a bottle okay
and so uh that will cover that and
um let's see here
uh let's go there that covers the
waterfront
okay well thank you for sharing the
story let us hear from you because uh
he's going to recover very quickly uh
the pancreas is a hard work and organ
you know it works 24 hours a day and so
by giving it the raw materials and they
held the granted heart attack and but
then giving it the ultimate enzymes
right
which has pancreatic enzymes in there to
help support the activity but but it's
it's the nutrition
which is required by your hard-working
art organs like your brain your heart
your your liver your kidneys your
pancreas all those things need a lot of
nutrition because they're working 24 7.
make sense yes it does absolutely thank
you doc have a blessed day no thank you
YouTube God bless you for helping people
thank you all right thank you Jill
well um Dr Wallach I think we had a
great show covered a lot of information
reached around the world
um
I think it's absolutely fantastic again
so you're talking
uh soft Poached Eggs let's talk a little
bit about what that means okay or soft
scrambled eggs
you're cooking at very low heat folks
and yes it's gonna take longer but
you're not killing that cholesterol
that the body needs your cholesterol you
want the cholesterol I want that
cholesterol absolutely
so with soft poached eggs
I put two tablespoons of butter and some
people is like oh that's a lot of butter
yes it is and it tastes fabulous
um but I get that so that it's just
melted not bubbly not sizzly and then I
crack my eggs into it and then I cover
it with a lid I like to use the clear
lid that way I can see what's going on
because I don't want to overcook my eggs
I want that white
that's covering the eggs and especially
if you're using fresh eggs
um you have more of that white yolk uh
the white of the eggs
Rebecca why do we want the cholesterol
well because our brain is made up of
cholesterol it takes cholesterol to
create hormones estrogen and
testosterone the myelin sheath that
protects and covers all of our nerves is
made of cholesterol yeah you're 25 of
your brain and 25 of your spinal cord by
weight is cholesterol and so if you have
a Doctor Who's really leaning over you
and spitting on you as he's talking and
telling you to get rid of cholesterol
out of your life
um you need to change doctors
because it's like saying no oxygen for
you you'll rust inside if you take in
too much oxygen stop breathing
that be the same thing as saying no
cholesterol
well and let's look at the effects of
that Dr Wallach since the
introduction of
specific Pharmaceuticals
that cut and reduce cholesterol
we have more heart disease we have more
cognitive
and neurological
diseases shorter life spans
more conditions that
are associated with nerve function
clear thinking brain fog is huge
um
stop using cholesterol
and here's something else
I just want to encourage if you are
taking one of these drugs look at that
insert that comes with your with your
pharmaceutical when you pick it up from
the pharmacy and if you don't have it in
that bag demand it
and look through all of the side effects
especially I mean common not common
doesn't matter
but when you've got body aching all over
it's one of the first side effects of
taking this drug
foreign so let's think about it okay
you're taking a drug to cut cholesterol
and then you've got body at the aches
all over your body and you go to the
doctor what does the doctor do he gives
you something else to help kill the pain
that you're experiencing all over when
all you need to do is get it's all in
your head
spoke in the CD book in the CD the book
and the CD
and take the 90 essential nutrients
and you don't have to worry about it and
I wanted to go back real quick Dr
Wallach you said 80 billion with a B
used
to treat asthma in kids under the age of
10. that's just treating asthma kids
under the age of 10. it doesn't say
anything about the kids over the age of
10. if it was scary to death
yeah and I wanted to add in that 300
billion about 300 billion to meet the
kids over age
so if you're looking at the kids Toddy
and a bottle of vfas
you're getting your child what that
child needs
to help
get away from that don't forget the eggs
don't forget the eggs and and working
paying very close attention to the food
that they're eating but you can do that
for less than seventy dollars a month
and as for a child that is 75 pounds
okay so what I've worked up in in
numbers I'm just kind of this number
geek
um is almost for every pound
that's about what it's going to cost
when you're working with children a
dollar a pound
per per day
okay or per month actually sorry per
month per month
so it's simple it's worth it
and as parents grandparents
I think it's our calling to make sure
that our kids and our grandkids are
getting what they need so that they can
enjoy life later on
we're out of time
and
Dr Wallach I just want to thank you
again another thing let's thank Jesse
for coming on well and well thank Jesse
yes I want to thank my co-hosts
for being here and keeping everything
rolling smoothly in
in the chat Nancy says thanks to askdoc
live team thank you Nancy
um you know we just appreciate all of
you and warriors miles are all smiling
it's beautiful
yeah
here because
because we want to share this
information because it has touched us
in a positive way
and it can do the same for you whether
it's just physically or whether it's
financially folks we can make an impact
in our own life in our family and our
communities and around the world
by sharing this information
and where it's not costing 80 billion
dollars a year to treat a single
childhood condition
we're asking you to give us 90 days and
you'll feel the difference of course
you're going to want to continue to go
on with taking the 90 essential
nutrients just because that's like
putting gas in your car you want your
car to continue to go you're going to
continue to give the body what it needs
so it can go strong
and that's what here on askdoc live
is presenting to you the option to do
that get back with the person that
invited you to this program they took
the time to share it with you tell them
how much you appreciate them
and on behalf of myself and the team
John to mccallier Dr Judy Reynolds Ruth
Ellen Sanchez and nasima Omar today
and Dr Wallach thank you everybody for
joining us on askdoc live again go to
askdocklive.com to catch the replay of
this program and we'll see you next time
on askdoc live my name is Rebecca Dix
Kozak bye for now
bye-bye Rebecca thank you for everything
thank you team God bless
God bless Dr Wallach thank you